this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for the really kind
and extensive introduction I maybe don't
even need to get my talk now
um can everybody hear me all right in
the back with the mic it's working
cool all right so it's my pleasure to be
here today and thank you guys all for
taking time out of your schedule to come
and listen to me talk about my science
and yeah I'm excited to share a bit
about my empirical work on Resurrection
plans
and also some of this emerging work on
looking at inequities in plant science
so I've divided my talk today into two
parts I'm going to begin maybe spend the
first 20 or 25 minutes talking about the
empirical work I'm doing studying
Resurrection plans primarily in South
Africa
and then the shift gears completely for
the second part of the talk and discuss
our recent work on quantifying and
describing some inequities in
that science
okay let me actually see if I can get
rid of this little
okay there we go
I thought I might start out by giving a
little bit of background about myself
just so you have a sense of where I came
from and and more or less how I arrived
where I am today
so I grew up in New Hampshire not all
that far from here and I spent my
teenage years working on small-scale
Vegetable Farms
and this gave me a real appreciation for
plants and plant production systems and
I actually thought I would have a career
in in agriculture and in farming but it
didn't take me long to realize that that
work is extremely hard
um physically and so I I sort of veered
away from that
and during my 20s I had the opportunity
to travel quite extensively some of
these travels were supported through my
schooling and my research activities but
most of them were actually really in
pursuit of my rock climbing hobby so not
academic at all
but these travels took me to some really
amazing and far-flung places in the
world
and one of the things that that really
stood out to me as I was traveling was
just how widespread and devastating the
effects of drought were in many of the
regions that I visited
and so this in addition to realizing
that farming was really hard work uh led
me back to Academia and I started
working on a PhD in plant science
and my work has really been centered
around
all right
so my work has really been centered
around this question of how can we make
the most out of an increasingly arid
world so not only is drought a problem
today or 10 years ago when I was
traveling and making these observations
but as you all I think appreciate
drought is predicted to increase in many
of the food producing regions of the
world in the coming decades
and now I think there's a lot of ways
that we can and should think about
answering this question or optimizing
sustainability and food Security in an
increasingly arid world and all of these
approaches should be pursued in parallel
that being said the approach that I've
decided to um
focus on for the time being is to
understand the biology of organisms that
are naturally adapted to thrive in arid
biomes
and that we can then leverage this
understanding for some of our own
applied objectives whether that be
engineering more resilient crops or
improving management strategies for arid
habitats or even understanding how to
preserve tissues in a dry State rather
than in a frozen state
so
I'm a plant biologist and I think many
of you guys are so if we look to the
natural world we see
um
which school doesn't want to advance
we see a number of natural adaptations
that have evolved across the plant
kingdom to cope with drought
some of these you're going to be very
familiar with seeds or succulents are
very successive successful strategies
for dealing with periods of water
scarcity but the adaptation that really
piqued my interest is that of
desiccation tolerance
desiccation tolerance is pictured in
these three gifts at the top
and it allows these vegetative tissues
of of these plants to survive nearly the
complete dehydration of their tissues
they can persist in this dry and dormant
state for months to years on end
but they rehydrate and resume normal
photosynthesis and Metabolism within
hours to days of re-wed
plants with disability and their
vegetative tissues are sort of commonly
referred to as Resurrection plants
because of their ability to quote
unquote resurrect from what looks like a
dead and dormant state
so this is a really beautiful and
fascinating adaptation and as I
mentioned previously there's a lot of
potential applications for this for some
of our own sort of human-centric uh
goals
so desiccation tolerance in plants has a
long and interesting evolutionary
history
it's thought to have evolved around 500
million years ago and was critical in
facilitating the transition out of the
Aquatic environment and into the
terrestrial environment by early land
plants
throughout evolutionary time desiccation
tolerance was lost in the vegetative
tissues of most vascular plants but it
was retained in most seeds
and then vegetative desiccation
tolerance re-evolve in a subset of
vascular plants that are located in
extremely arid or water limited habitats
and it's thought to re-evolve
convergently through the rewiring of
ancestral Pathways that were maintained
in seeds
in contrast desiccation tolerance was
maintained in many bryophytes and other
early diverging lineages and this is
thought to be a consequence of the fact
that bryophytes lack some other
adaptations or structures for water
transport and retention such as stomata
and vasculature and therefore it was
more necessary to maintain desiccation
tolerance
so because of this evolutionary history
or as a result we end up with a
distribution of extant or living
desiccation tolerant species that looks
like this
so what I'm showing you here let me use
my pointer
is the land plant phylogeny at the
family level starting with bryophytes
Ferns and fern allies and then
angiosperms in green
every family that's written on here in
blue which I know you can't read
um
has at least one desiccation tolerant
species in it that has been described so
there's probably many more that we
haven't even described
um but what I hope you can appreciate
from this figure is that desiccation
tolerance is really common among the
early diverging lineages of bryophytes
and to some extent Ferns and fern allies
but by the time we get to angiosperms
desiccation tolerance is only found in
nine arguably ten uh families of
angiosperms and they're really quite uh
distantly related
so it's thought to have re-evolved
convergently in these lineages possibly
by rewiring similar Pathways that were
maintained in seeds
so we think this is a really exciting
opportunity to study the convergent
evolution of a complex trait
and by doing this one of our goals is to
identify sorry Identify some of the core
mechanisms that might be retained or
shared across these diverse lineages
so I just wanted to give an example of
what this diversity looks like I think
these pictures help drive home the
message so what I'm showing you here are
three different species of Resurrection
plants we have a liver wart Ricky
okhandra a dicot Linda
and a Monica zerified a humulus
these plants are separated by nearly 500
million years of evolution
yet we can find them growing in these
closely intertwined communities in the
same habitat
and responding to the stress of drying
in a very similar way so all of these
species can dry down to about 10
relative water content and yet they all
recover really beautifully within about
24 to 48 hours of re-wetting
so as I said we wanted to take advantage
of this system to try to understand or
Identify some of the core or shared
mechanisms of this trait
so initially we thought we could do this
by taking advantage of publicly
available sequencing data so there's
been quite a lot of sequencing projects
on all sorts of plants including
Resurrection plans and so we went out
and combed through ncbi to find all of
the rna-seq data sets of Resurrection
plants that had been sampled you know as
they dried and then recovered we were
able to gather data for about 18
different desiccation tolerant taxa we
don't have perfect phylogenetic
representation but we did span from
bryophytes to ferns to angiosperms
I really won't bore you with the details
but we did a bunch of bioinformatic
analysis to identify orthologous genes
and summarize the patterns of expression
across this data set
and really simply put what we found was
that there was no pattern at all related
to desiccation in these species we found
that so this plot is just a PCA of gene
expression and they're colored by
species
um
and what you're looking at here is every
single species clustered in its own
unique cluster irregardless of its
hydration status
we thought
what is going on here I mean maybe each
one of these species really does have a
unique mechanism for surviving
desiccation
however we don't suspect this is true
because we know from physiological
studies that there are shared responses
that have to happen to survive
desiccation so
um I won't go into the molecular details
but there are a number of processes that
we know are necessary for survival of
desiccation
so an alternative explanation to this
pattern we're observing is that each one
of these studies was collected by a
different lab a different researcher in
a different year
and people tend to impose drought
stresses in different ways and Sample it
different ways so we thought we might be
picking up on experimental variation uh
in these public data and we really
couldn't find a way to differentiate
between whether or not this was
experimental variation or or true
biology biological differences between
these species
so we actually abandoned this project
completely and decided that the solution
was to develop what we would call let me
read this as a kind of arrogant way to
say it but a gold standard data set that
could minimize variation between
researchers and labs
and a data set like this could be
generated by sampling all of this
diversity in a single experiment
and it's sort of no surprise but it
turned out we were really well poised to
generate such a data set so
at this point I had been working in
South Africa for a couple of years I've
been working on single species projects
but I had observed at one of my field
sites that there were a dozen or more
diverse Resurrection plans and this is
just a selection of them that could be
found growing in really close proximity
to one another
and we thought okay this is a cool
opportunity we can go to the field and
collect samples from these diverse
plants in a common environment under a
common uh conditions
and so this is a really large project
that I've been working on over
um the past year or so so last year I
went to this field site and I'm just
showing you some preliminary data here
so we
I should say I actually
um collected
these time courses for each of these 16
species in the field so it basically
went out to the field when the plants
were in the hydrated condition and
started collecting tissue and
physiological data for them over the
course of two weeks
they drive down and then I just sat
around and waited for it to ring and as
soon as it rained it ran back out to the
field and started collecting the
rehydration time points
and so what I'm showing you here this is
just the physiological data showing the
relative water content in red and the
photosynthetic efficiency or scfm in
blue
over the two-week time course and um
what I hope you can see is that pretty
much all of these species dehydrated to
very low relative water content
photosynthesis shuts down almost
completely and yet they all recover uh
within a few days of rainfall now we see
different kinetics of how quickly they
dry or how quickly they recover but we
think we've collected
um a pretty inclusive uh and and
comprehensive uh set of data for these
plants
now this is as far as I've got on this
project so far what we're doing now is
we've collected tissue for each of these
time points in each of these species and
we're targeting like a massive
transcriptomic and metabolomic study for
all of these and we hope that this data
set will allow us to answer that
question and see if there are there any
core mechanisms that are shared across
this large phylogenetic distance or do
we see different mechanisms in
bryophytes versus angiosperms which has
been hypothesized
so I'm excited about this data set I
hope you are too and like please follow
up in a couple years and see what we
find
in the meantime
we've been trying to ask a similar
question but on a more narrow
phylogenetic scale so we've been working
with three different Resurrection
grasses these are all native to Southern
Africa
and as I said these species are more
related but they are separated by about
10 to 20 million years of evolution and
they're all in different genuses so we
have
um tripogon Minimus microflua kaphra and
oropecia compensate
and all three of these species are
Resurrection plants and they're
desiccation tolerant
and they're also really nice to work
with they're grasses they produce a lot
of seed and we can grow them up in just
a few months and and replicate them and
conduct experiments on them
so what we did for this project again
the goal here was to try to test if
there were shared mechanisms between
these grasses
so the first thing we did was we
generated genome assemblies for these
three species we use only long read pack
biodata and for tripogon and orepishium
we were able to generate nearly
chromosome level
assemblies but these species have
relatively small genomes and they're
diploid for microcloa it's hexaploid and
it has a much larger genome and so we
were not able to get to chromosome level
but we do still cover most of the gene
space with this assembly
we then uh collected these drying time
courses similar to what I showed you in
the field but in this case these were
done using replicated sets of plants in
a growth chamber and so we drive them
down over the course of two weeks and
rehydrated and what I'm showing you here
again is the same data on relative water
content and photosynthetic efficiency so
they all dried they stopped
photosynthesizing and they recovered
we collected
um rna-seq data for each of these time
points and if we just plot sort of the
basic PCA of gene expression for each of
the species individually we see a pretty
nice separation of samples so in general
hydrated samples tend to Cluster
together
the dry samples form another cluster and
rehydrated samples form a third cluster
so we think we had a pretty good quality
data sets
and um so the next step was to actually
ask our question are there shared
mechanisms here uh in order to do that
we identified all of the synthetic
orthologs between these species and we
then plotted the same kind of PCA of
gene expression based on the satanic
orthologs or the genes that were shared
among the species and what I'm showing
you here is the same plot colored two
ways in the bottom it's colored by the
species identity and what I hope you can
see here is that the species are really
kind of mixed together
in the top plot um the samples are
instead colored by water content
and what I hope you can see here is that
we do sort of see a signal of like
hydrated plant plants in one section and
more of the dehydrated plants forming
another cluster it's a little bit messy
but this encouraged us to think okay
there there seems to be a consistent
signal of dehydration across these
through species
so as you do the next thing we did was
look at differential Express genes
and um what I'm showing you here is just
the number of genes that were
differentially expressed in the three
species in dehydration and rehydration
so we have upregulated genes and down
regulated genes I just want to make a
couple points with this plot so
dehydration induces major changes in
gene expression we see thousands of
genes that are upregulated and down
regulated in these species it's a
quarter to a third of the genome is
differentially expressed during this
time course
in general the genes that were
upregulated during dehydration are then
down regulated during rehydration and
vice versa so what goes up comes down
and we return to homeostasis
if we look at patterns across the
species
oh why can't you see those
there we go
okay
we find sorry that's a bit hard to see I
know you guys can't see the numbers but
what I'm showing you here is the overlap
as a Venn diagram between the
differentially expressed genes and the
three species and you I don't think you
can read those numbers but we find about
25 to 20 percent of these genes are
shared or differentially upregulated in
all three species
we then looked at um keg annotations
which is a more General way to look at
the metabolic function or the predicted
metabolic function of these genes and if
we look at the same plot of overlap
between K terms we find even higher
conservation going from about 40 to 35
percent so this suggests a couple things
I mean one there's quite a bit of shared
gene expression two we find more shared
a processes at a metabolic level than at
a single Gene level which we might
expect so if you have sort of a slightly
different Gene but you still want to
arrive at the same end goal
um I don't think I really need to talk
too much about this heat map but this is
just a clustering of the differentially
expressed Peg terms and what I'd like to
point out here is that these are it
falls out in these nice clusters of
these are all the genes that are
upregulated during rehydration in the
three species
and these are down regulated during
dehydration and vice versa so we really
are seeing evidence that there are
shared patterns across these three
grasses
we try to dig into what those shared
processes are that seemed like the next
logical step and so to do that we
conducted uh Gene ontology enrichment
analysis
so what I'm showing you here is just a
cluster of the enriched Gene ontology
terms in the different conditions in
different species
and what you see is we find these like
pretty distinct clusters of these are
the genes that are up during dehydration
and down during rehydration in the three
species and these are the ones that are
up during rehydration
we can dig into what those functions are
and um
yeah sorry I can't see that huh
um okay but I'll just tell you anyway so
these are the uh shared enriched go
terms across the three species during
dehydration and the processes that we
see coming up are in fact the Hallmarks
of desiccation tolerance so we see major
modifications to carbohydrate metabolism
to favor the production and accumulation
of small non-reducing sugars that
function to form glasses and stabilize
the cellular environment in a dry state
we also see major upregulation of
antioxidant systems to deal with free
radicals that are created during a
partially hydrated systems and from
photo oxidative damage
we see other modifications to
transcription and translation as well as
cellular organization during this time
during rehydration again we see many of
the processes that we would expect to
see in recovery from desiccation so we
see the resumption of photosynthesis and
pigment biosynthesis to repair damaged
chlorophyll and protein modification to
repair and recycle damaged proteins
so not only are a lot of genes shared
across these species but they're also
represent the Hallmarks of desiccation
tolerance which we expect to see
um we did a whole bunch of other
analyzes that I'm not going to talk
about at all just to say that we found
really similar patterns so we looked at
co-expressed genes and the overlap
between the co-express modules we looked
at uh we conducted topological data
analysis to understand the sort of
underlying shape of the data and in all
of these cases we find a stronger signal
of stress
than of species identity
so the overwhelming pattern in this data
set is that stress is predictive of gene
expression above and beyond species
identity
so just to summarize this section of the
talk
um I'm running short on time
I've told you that the application
induces major changes in gene expression
dehydration or rehydration processes are
largely inverse although there are some
specific things so what goes up comes
down and vice versa
we see high overlap between these
species and it's even higher if you look
at a metabolic level uh versus a single
Gene level
the shared processes are the Hallmarks
of deslocation Tolerance
and I don't think I mentioned this but
we see higher overlap in general during
dehydration than during rehydration
and the explanation for this or my idea
for an explanation for this is that
desiccation stress is really intense and
kind of overwhelming and uh the plants
will divert almost all of their
attention to dealing with the stress of
desiccation
during rehydration
they might start to resume species
specific functions related to
reproduction or other processes and that
could explain the higher overlap during
desiccation compared to the hydration
so overall we think there's evidence to
say that there is a set of core
mechanisms that are shared at least
among these grasses and future studies
will hopefully allow us to tell if
they're shared more broadly across a
larger phylogenetic scale
yeah okay so I might Buzz through this
section pretty quickly but I have a
little bit more to say about desiccation
tolerance before we talk about
representation and equity
so
one of my other approaches to trying to
understand the mechanism of desiccation
tolerance is to narrow down a whole lot
so I just told you about these sort of
broad sweeping analyzes looking across
huge phylogenetic distances
that's great for identifying deeply
conserved processes but we're also ident
interested in identifying single genes
or traits that can enhance tolerance
and so for this uh I've been working on
identifying locally adapted populations
or populations that show natural
variation in desiccation tolerance and
we can then hone in to see what are the
underlying traits that are driving this
variation
foreign this is a concept or an approach
that I've been thinking about for for a
very long time so as Margaret mentioned
my PhD work was markancia and flexa a
liver award and we looked at natural
variation in this system
and then the first two years of my
post-doc work were devoted to this
really amazing species myrathamus
flavafolia where I'd hope to ask some of
the same questions
um
as it turned out my resoundness was not
a great system for this so it is widely
distributed but it's a woody uh slow
growing plant and we were unable to
propagate it clonally so I couldn't
generate replicates and I couldn't bring
it into culture in the lab
so
it turned out to not be a very
attractable system for this but it is
still a really amazing plant it has a
lot of cultural importance and medicinal
applications
um and we did put out a small study on
the Ecology of the species
but as I was working on my rathamness I
stumbled across microcloa one of the
grasses I mentioned previously and
microkloa had really obvious phenotypic
variation across the sites I was looking
in and so I thought geez maybe this is
just
um the world's way of showing me this is
the species I should be working on and
so we started trying to ask these
questions in microcloa
the general approach for all of these
studies was really similar the idea was
to screen natural populations
to see if they had differences in their
ability to recover from desiccation
and then to try to associate these with
other traits from life history to
physiology to genetics
so
as I said I'm going to talk a little bit
about the work in microcloa um this work
is supported by a Wally the water Life
Institute so I should acknowledge them
thank you
and um what I've done so far with this
species is to the idea was to generate a
small like a mini diversity panel well I
mean really we like a large diversity
panel but it's just me and it takes time
to to make these collections so I've
started out
um and have sampled 11 populations
across an environmental gradient in
South Africa the sites range from these
low elevation hot dry sites
to much higher elevation cooler weather
sites
um the sites are about 500 kilometers in
distance
um
a couple maybe 500 meters in elevation
and significant differences in rainfall
so we collected plants from all of these
sites and we phenotyped them both in the
field and we phenotype progeny in a
common environment
um we measured a bunch of traits and we
found a bunch of differences so
we first looked at sort of basic
morphology
um I'll walk you through these really
quick so
this is panicle length so the length of
the the seed or flower I guess in
fluorescence
we find that plants from the hot dry
sites which are generally in these
oranger colors uh had a much larger
panicles than plants from the wet sites
they also had much longer and wider
leaves but they produced far fewer
panicles so the plants from the wet site
were very reproductive but they were
much smaller and bushier
I think the most interesting piece of
evidence that we have differences
between these sites is that the
the plants from these uh hot and dry
sites had nearly double the size of
their genomes compared to the high
elevation site so the high elevation
sites these are already hexaploid this
was the one we did the genome assembly
on but these plants from the hot dry
sides are up to maybe dodecaport we
haven't actually done the karyotyping
but just based on genome size you have
massive genomes
and um
and people often like to ask are these
even the same species
well I don't even know what a species is
anymore
but if we submit these to the herbarium
they come back with the same species
identity and
um you know as we work up the genetics
we might be able to tell more about
genetic Divergence and and
wave our hands about the species
um
so we have some interesting uh
phenotypic differences we then wanted to
characterize differences in desiccation
tolerance so what we did is we tried
down all the plants and we and we
measured their recovery um this is just
their photosynthesis and and this is
just here to show that all the plants
dried and they all recovered and these
are visual representation so all of the
plants recovered but they recovered to a
different degree so we measure the
proportion of tissue that recovered in
each of these accessions after
dehydration so we always lose some
tissue to senescence during a
desiccation event but that amount can
vary
and um I'm going to show a video that I
think
helps to drive home this point so this
is the large ecotype from the hot Drive
sites this is the small ecotype from the
wet cool sides and what I hope these
over the time same time scale what I
hope you can see is that this larger
ecotype is uh recovering a lot more
screening up a lot more than this other
one
and we we do find significant
differences in the proportion of tissue
that we covers
so this was pretty exciting for me and
taken together we described two Echo
types of the species so we have a high
elevation ecotype that is characterized
by small plants with lower ploidy
lower recovery from desiccation
but increase reproduction
and we have this hot dry ecotype which
there's some evidence of local
adaptation here right because they're
recovering better from desiccation in
the sites that are drier
and this is also associated with higher
employee
and reduced reproduction now I could
spend another 15 minutes talking about
the potential trade-offs and the
mechanisms that might be behind this but
I think for the sake of time I'll save
that for the questions
um and just summarize this section by
saying
desiccation tolerance is still evolving
and we have evidence or preliminary
evidence that there are locally adopted
populations that exist across this
environmental gradient of aridity
and that these are associated with
changes in ploidy now we can't say Floyd
is driving increased desiccation
tolerance it's a complex three-way
interaction but it's possible that
polyploidy and genome duplication might
enhance existing desiccation tolerance
mechanisms by either providing higher a
copy number of important endpoint
metabolites or possibly allowing new
copies of these genes to be
neo-functionalized into protective
functions
okay
so oh yeah I wanted to say one more
thing about my work on Resurrection
plans so this has been a really
um fun and exciting opportunity for me
to combine my longtime hobby of rock
climbing with my research on plant
science
Resurrection plants tend to grow on
vertical cliffsides and so I've been
able to use my my rope access skills to
abseil over these Cliffs and make
Collections and of plants that really
haven't been studied very much before
and um
yeah so this is whatever it's been fun
for me but I also think it's one of the
aspects about research and Academia that
I really appreciate
um is that this career sort of allows us
the space to creatively combine some of
our unique skills and do things that
you know other people might not think to
do or companies might not support us to
do and and so this is just an example of
why I personally love Academia and and I
just think it it provides a lot of
opportunities for creativity
okay so with that
I think maybe like 10 minutes was up
all right I'm gonna shift gears
completely and um I want to talk about
this other aspect of my work which has
been focused on
um identifying and describing some of
the persistent inequities that exist in
in our field of plant science but I
suspect these are are sort of broadly
true across other scientific disciplines
uh so this work is
oh how can I say it um this work is more
personal to me and it was really born
out of the time that I've spent uh
working in South Africa working with the
amazing biodiversity there and the
brilliant scientists
and um but some of the observations that
I was picking up on in terms of
to me what seemed like really striking
differences in in access to resources
and facilities and opportunities uh
between uh my work at Michigan State and
the work in in Cape Town and
I wanted to put I wanted to test if
these observations were
were real and put some data behind
behind these observations and test if if
these inequities did exist and if so
what were the implications of them
uh you know and I also spent a lot of
time reflecting about what it meant to
be
a scientist coming from the United
States studying biodiversity in southern
Africa which is a history that has a
long and and complicated and difficult
history of colonialism and
how can I do this work ethically
um and so yes all of these thoughts were
swirling around in my head and then
covet happened and I thought wow okay
this is an opportunity to explore some
other questions
and so as Margaret said over the past
couple years we've we've conducted a
couple's sort of medium to large scale
meta-analyzes to try to quantify the
patterns and the progress and the
inequities in plant science over the
past 20 years so
I don't have time to talk about both of
these studies but they
were similar in their thrust and many of
the conclusions were really similar
across both of these so
the first study which I'm not going to
talk about today we surveyed all of the
species that had their genomes assembled
and we looked at who was doing that
research and what species had been
sequenced and we found some pretty
striking
um inequities both in terms of human
participation as well as taxonomic
representation
okay this isn't intriguing but can we
see how broad this pattern is let's
scale up and look across plant science
more broadly
so we then set out to a survey about 300
000 papers that were published in plant
science over the past 20 years we Source
these from a range of journals about 125
plant science journals spanning impact
factors and subject areas and to the
best of our ability national locations
but there's even a bias there and um
maybe I don't even need to say this but
this data set is not comprehensive but
we do think it's representative of what
the plant science literature looks like
okay so the first thing we wanted to do
is just look at the distribution of
where plant science authors are based
and
what we found is that plant science
authors are largely concentrated in
these three main regions of the world in
the United States in Central and Western
Europe and in China
there are you know noteworthy
contributions from other regions of the
world but there are also large swaths of
the globe that have a very small or
reduced footprint in the plant science
literature
we found that the patterns of where
plant science papers are produced and
published are really tightly correlated
with national GDP and National research
and development expenditure so in
general wealthier countries tend to
invest more in research and development
and this leads to more Publications
now there are some I think interesting
case studies of Nations that are
publishing either far more or far less
than would be predicted based on their
investment and these are
intriguing case studies to follow up on
and see what's what are the factors at
play in these nations that are either
promoting or discouraging publishing
implant science
now
certainly research and development
expenditure outputs may be found in
other sectors in some of these other
countries that are not even scientific
or academic but in terms of
companies and Industry
um but in general we see that affluence
is highly correlated with publication
rates in plant science and just as sort
of a side point maybe this is obvious to
say but Global affluence is one not
equal and two has been largely
determined by our Colonial history which
has led to the consolidation of wealth
and Prestige and scientific resources in
select locations of the world and it
seems that this is uh having an effect
on on where plant science research is
being done
we also looked at how these patterns
scaled with population density so in
general you would expect to see
um increased productivity uh in any
field with increased population density
and this is what we see across the globe
in general like more populous areas
produce more plant science papers
um however there are a number of
locations that fall either above or
below that Global mean
so the the Dots here in green are
locations where uh we're publishing a
lot more papers than expected based on
the population density and and pink is
the inverse so these are really populous
areas that are not publishing a ton of
papers
um so what I'd like to point out here is
that this skews the the situation even
further so we already we're producing a
lot of papers in America but they're
also coming out of very rural regions
um same in Australia and parts of
Northern Europe now I think this makes
sense for plant science uh in some sense
plant science is is almost inherently
linked to Natural spaces and rural areas
a more agricultural spaces and and in
the United States you know we have a lot
of land grant institutes in in rural
areas that are publishing a lot of
papers in plant science
um
but it's
maybe it's noteworthy or problematic
because the United States and Europe
together account for less than 10 of the
global rural population and yet like 64
65 of the plant science papers are
published out of these regions so this I
think contributes to the exclusion of
rural people's perspectives from other
regions of the world
foreign and maybe this is a good point
to say
um
why I think that's a problem
um I think we can all probably come up
with a lot of reasons why this is a
problem but I would just highlight two
here
um one by not including the voices of
peoples from these other regions of the
world we are missing out on their
expertise and wisdom
secondly
if the science is being done and led by
people in select regions of the world
we're almost certainly prioritizing
the things that matter to us in those
regions of the world and they may be
different from the priorities of people
living in some of these underrepresented
regions of the world and so if we want
to uh really create an inclusive and
well-rounded Global Science landscape I
think
it would behoove us to try to include
some more of these voices and
perspectives from other parts of the
world
so we actually got home maybe this is
happening maybe there is a really oh I'm
jumping ahead
um this is just a depressing stat but we
also looked at citation rates across
these data sets and we found that
um citation reads some sort of random
they've increased a bit and they're a
bit noisy but in general authors from
North America from China
and from Europe
and Oceania are cited nearly twice as
much as authors from other parts of the
global South
so I don't I don't know I think this is
kind of depressing because we as
individuals are the ones who are making
choices about what we cite and uh maybe
we're just citing the people that we
know
um and are aware of their work uh
but I think we could probably do more to
try to cite authors from other regions
of the world as a way to amplify those
voices
so yeah we thought maybe the voices of
people from underrepresented parts of
the world were being engaged through
collaboration networks but in fact this
is not the case international and
InterContinental collaborations were
extremely uncommon in this database so
70 of the papers were written by authors
from just a single nation
now many of these papers include 5 10 15
authors but they were all from the same
nation and but 22 involved two Nations
and five percent involved three or more
Nations
so there's an opportunity to diversify
our collaboration networks and and this
is not to say or to diminish the work of
anybody
um in science or in this room who's been
working really hard to develop
International collaborations and
inclusive science I know that it's
happening
um
on an individual level but across the
whole field the pattern is really
dominated by some specific regions of
the world and that they tend to be a bit
more insular
we also look at gender Dynamics so we
were interested to see if there was
gender inequity in plant science
publishing in order to do this we had to
use an imperfect method of inferring
author's identity based on their first
name so these gender inference
algorithms uh don't always get it right
and they almost certainly misidentify
anybody that's non-binary or gender
non-conforming and so
um maybe I don't need to say all of this
but we don't presume to know the true
identity of any of the authors but
across this entire data set of 300 000
papers and that's just 300 000 papers so
it's also like 900 000 authors or more
we think that these patterns are
probably illustrative
in general
um authors with what do we call it names
normatively associated with masculinity
published nearly twice as many papers as
authors with names associated with
femininity
we do see some Regional differences in
how these gender ratios exist so authors
from
there are parts of the world like Latin
America and Eastern Europe that have a
more a female participation but most of
the regions of the world that are really
publishing a lot of plant science papers
are are still quite male biased
similar to Continental differences we
also see that male authors tend to be
cited more than female authors despite
publishing in similar impact factor
level journals
and and finally so gender am I yeah
gender ratios have increased some over
time but not as much as we could there's
still lag well below 50
um I know you guys are all dying to see
this part about which plants are most
studied so we looked to see yeah no
surprises right
um a robin office baleana is studied in
four times as many studies as the next
most common species wheat followed by
Maize you have to go well below the top
50 before you find anything that's not a
model or a major crop species
and um we also looked at statistical
over and under representation of studies
on different orders of land plants
um and we find that there's a real
over-representation of economically and
agriculturally important plants and an
underrepresentation of wild and
biodiverse plants this is not to say
that studying crops is a bad thing it's
led to a lot of agricultural Innovations
and scientific breakthroughs but it may
have come at the cost of exploring some
of these more biodiverse species which
are threatened by Extinction and also
have a lot of really amazing secondary
chemistry that could be mined for human
activities if we look across different
nations we see that there's actually a
really different prioritization of study
organisms and so a lot of these nations
that are leading plant science are
following the same pattern of studying
arabidopsis followed by major crops
we get down to some of these nations
that have a smaller footprint implant
science we see a different
prioritization of study species and so
this suggests that if we could broaden
participation at a human level we might
see natural diversification of study
systems and scientific questions
I'm going to skip the take-home messages
because we are out of time
and I'm going to talk about this slide
really briefly and then we'll just go to
questions if there's time so
I always want to end my talks with an
acknowledgment of the many quote unquote
failures or setbacks that I've had in my
career
um I think that this is a normal process
of doing science when you're asking
questions and trying techniques that
have never been done before there are
some things that just don't work and
understanding that this is part of the
project and it's not a personal failure
it doesn't mean you're a bad scientist
um I think is worth doing so if you're
in this room and you're struggling with
with your science and things aren't
working just know that I've experienced
a lot of setbacks and I imagine almost
everybody else in this room has and have
learned a ton from all of them
um
so with that
um I'm starting my own lab next year at
University of Illinois if anybody's
interested or know somebody that might
want to join we're going to keep working
on all the stuff I talked about today
and um
yeah I'll get that I'll just I'll just
say a lot of people helped me do this
workout and do it alone
um sorry for running over time and I'd
be happy to take questions if there's
times
picture
yes and no so some of the species are
amenable to growing in the lab the
grasses have been great because they
produce a lot of seed we could easily
germinate them other species have been
really hard to bring into cultivation
um they're bigger plants they're harder
to grow from seed uh there's also a
a technical logistical and ethical
consideration because these are South
African species so I have tried to where
I could study them in the field
or I couldn't do that bring them into a
culture in the greenhouse of the
University of Cape Town with my
collaborators and when we couldn't do
that bring them back to the United
States with all sorts of like
um legal agreements about who owns the
German Plaza and whatnot so
if you're thinking about doing this if
you can find a species that you can
bring into the lab it really helps it
makes the science a lot easier but when
in doubt you can do these experiments in
the field we've we just go out there
with a huge liquid nitrogen doer and all
of our equipment and
um make our collections in the field but
the data is a bit noisier
well it depends on your question we've
been doing time courses
um because we want to see how things are
changing as they dry and rehydrate um
and if you're comparing different
species you could you might get away
with one time point
yeah I think it's really cool to do it
in the natural environment and we have
one study that have collected field
samples and done RNA c-con and actually
the data looks really good
um it's a logistically a little bit more
difficult
um to get this stuff out there and if
the weather doesn't cooperate so one
season I spent like a month sitting
there waiting for it to rain and it
never did and so we brought out water
and cans
it comes with its own challenges yeah
who's maning the questions
like what's up for grad students
yeah so I had a similar question so uh
collaborating with uh
because of uh
fear of firefighters so
yes those issues exist and we've thought
about them a lot and I could say quite a
lot about it
um but the second part of the question I
have not had any resistance from my
collaborators in South Africa in fact
they are so excited when maybe this is
just the people I'm working with but
they are really happy to share the
species and if but the way I've
approached it is we have tried to
establish uh legal agreements specifying
that the germplasm and any potential
commercial applications Remain the
ownership under the ownership of the
University of Cape Town
um I mean really they should be under
the ownership of the indigenous
communities in those areas but that's
another question
um and we've also just tried to include
a co-authorship and real participation
from South African students and
collaborators in these projects and
where we can we keep the germ plas on
that side but there are some things that
are just a lot easier to do at Michigan
State than they are at Cape Town and
yeah I mean and and the other thing is
the United States hasn't ratified Nagoya
protocol so you can get away with just
being a cowboy and doing this stuff but
we need to all like take that
responsibility I think on ourselves and
and really try to find collaborators
um
have those agreements
did I answer my question
so I had a quick question about the uh
the RNC data that Evolution Southern
change that that were upregulated when
you have
um conditions
um what percentage of genes were
actually like roughly where stress
responsive compared to other biological
processes like I'm just trying to
understand whether it's all stress
adaptation or there are actually
relative processes that are getting well
I mean it's what is stress responsive so
I I'm not totally sure how to answer
that question if we look at like Gene
ontology terms where they've said this
is a stress responsive thing or this is
a carbohydrate metabolism thing then we
could say I would estimate that about of
the de genes
maybe 20 30 of them are these stress
responsive go terms
but I would argue that the modifications
to carbohydrate metabolism and the cell
wall modifications and the protein
modifications those are stress responses
as well
um I would actually argue that almost
everything that's upregulated during
that time is is a stress response but um
yeah if you're like just want to know
about antioxidants or um it would be a
smaller proportion
from the differences
that's a great question and it's not
something we've looked at
um so the only thing I can tell you
about stomata and these Resurrection
grasses
um
well I think that's a great idea I would
love to to do it if you want to
collaborate and you're still not an
expert
um we do see that the resurrection
grasses tend to dry really rapidly so
they'll hold on to their water until
about 70 to 80 percent then they dry
extremely rapidly and what we think the
explanation for that is they actually
open the stomata and rapidly expel water
so as to avoid uh time spent at these
intermediate hydration statuses which
are really dangerous because metabolic
reactions stop halfway through and you
get toxic intermediates
um so I think they're probably some very
interesting to model uh
Dynamics at play and I wanted to measure
stomodo conductance in the field last
year but
um I just didn't have the time I need a
field assistant
um so yeah
um
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu